abbas is here what happened
to the city thank you for having me
thanks for being here man a long time
yeah it has been you with the crash
course in 2019 yes i was
then the dfa yes come on oh wow
oh wow thank you that's very kind
hey what's up welcome back to my channel
we have another
winners on a wednesday story and i want
to introduce you to abbas and sahar and
they're going to share their story of
how they have become
successful in property they have hired
now nine
full-time members of staff they've got a
lot of units in birmingham right now
so welcome to abbas and zaha good to
have you on the show
well thank you for having us here thank
you well firstly congratulations on your
wedding last year
thank you thank you also congratulations
on your success in property
i actually i couldn't even remember how
many units you had because it's ever
growing so fast so you've got
nine members of staff yep and how many
how many property units are you
you have 250 units all together oh wow
commercial as well 200 no wonder i
couldn't remember the number you know
really really well that's really
impressive and you're doing rental rents
yes um now moving into development yes
so why don't you start by telling me a
little bit about
how this all started talk me through
from the beginning
okay i think my journey started
somewhere around january
2019 yeah um i
came across a friend who told me about
you know i was always finding ways on
how i can get into the business industry
right a friend of mine suggested my boss
why don't you start reading books
you know he told me if a statistic that
says that an average american reads
probably one book a year
and they don't even finish the book by
the end of the year and their
salary is probably around average
minimum wage yeah then an average ceo
reads one book a week that's about 52
weeks
52 books a year and he makes about 319
times
more than an average american i was like
whoa i need to start reading books yeah
so
i go in to start reading books then i
came across robert kiyosaki
went to his show i came across a few
guys
on the way and none of them were
actually delivering what i was expecting
like literally a guide
on how i can start a business how i can
go through it and
set up a solid business right i came
across sandy deja pulled my paul
mcfadden
i paid some money but it was all a fail
and then i came across samuel leeds on
youtube
and going through your content like
anybody watching this like i'd say your
content on youtube is so
valuable the content there i literally
took that as a university
spent i would wake up early morning till
night grab a book
sit in front of my laptop and just make
notes i did that for
a couple of months because i think your
shows were fully booked for at least two
months or so two to three months
so i just that was my day every day
spending time on your youtube channel
learning everything trying to figure out
the formulas you were giving out
how to do the due diligence what sperm
is all about and before coming on to
your show
i started making cold calls and there
was all just rejections and rejection
and rejection
and then i came to your show and then
moving from there the deal finally
extravaganza and i got my deal there one
of the deals there
so that's how really it started it's all
and at the time as well that's awesome
by the way i mean you're living in
birmingham now yes
where about were you living at this time
so i was
at this time when everything was
happening i was in dubai right and
that's where i've been born raised
um devised my home right so how did you
guys know
well she came down to london uh well
it's a long story we've been engaged for
three years
yeah we've been friends on social media
first introduced by a friend
yeah and then we met about four four
five years ago yes that's correct
and yeah we just met during a gathering
and
we just happened to see each other who
we knew as on social
media but we hadn't really seen each
other so i think that was kind of like a
spark in conversation
um and at that at that time i was
studying in toronto i was finishing off
my
degree bachelor's degree um so we
started texting and then we
decided to do things the right way so we
thought of like telling our parents
about it
and asking them you know are they okay
with it because we're
we're very like let's do things the
right way and let's you know
yeah yeah how did you feel talking of
the right way
when abbas started saying i'm going on
these property courses and what did
samuel leads on youtube and
and going like how did you feel about
that as the fiancee
of you know it really involved in the
future like
what was your thoughts so i do come from
a family who is very
um business oriented and in my family
i've always seen
everybody working really hard yeah and
they're all proper workaholics
so when he would say this i would be so
motivating like i would love it i tell
him you know like go for it do it
you know like i'm so happy and i tell
him that you know one day you're gonna
be on the show
you're gonna see it's gonna happen you
know you you can make wonders
so i always made him feel like you know
she was extremely supportive like i'll
tell you
that when i wanted to go on the shows
with uh
robert kiyosaki pulled my head and i
paid two three thousand pounds
and i got burnt there because they
didn't deliver and then there was three
shows not delivered so it was all a burn
and then i came across you and i was so
convinced that
this is it you know this is gonna work
but then i didn't have the
money in my bank account at the time
yeah um so
me taking borrowing money again for the
dfe
would have been a big step considering
that i've just lost so much money she
was actually like you have to do it
if you if you're convinced you have to
do it so she's been extremely supportive
and when you did my advanced training
the deal finally extravaganza was
against thousands of pounds yeah
yeah was it a burn no no well i'm here
now so
uh it's been extremely worth it yeah
what happened because this is like
where when was when did you attend the
deal finding extravaganza
i think i came to your show in july
august 2019 and then
i came for the dfe in december okay so
very back end of 2017 so about 18 months
ago yes
you say that you did your first deal on
the deal finding extravaganza yes tell
me about it
okay so uh i came across uh one of your
students for wiki ricky mandel yeah
right
he was talking about how he had about
300 rejections at the time
until he got his first deal but i was at
a point uh
where i had crossed over 700 to a
thousand rejections
i'd wake up in the morning start cold
calling every day
the thing that a big mistake i made was
that i wasn't understanding the
difference between sales and closing
once they tell me i'm not interested in
corporate let's i just hang up yeah
i wouldn't understand to empathize with
them and say hey i understand you don't
do corporal let's
and if i was you as an agent i probably
wouldn't do corporate less myself
because of all the bad experience you
probably have but let me explain you how
we do it differently
i didn't have that on i didn't have that
initially so all those rejections i was
like okay what can i do different
because i didn't have that knowledge at
the time
so let me wear a suit and tie and i
started knocking on their doors
i probably covered about mostly all the
areas in birmingham king's heat solihull
celly oak mosley get everywhere
uh knock on all their doors and
rejections over rejections
until i came across an agency in celio
where i knocked on the door probably
five times
until they gave me that my first deal so
you were really hustling
yes all right getting rejected a
thousand times
spending lots of money on training and
feeling you weren't getting anywhere
you came to the crash course a lot of
people would have been so deflated at
that point
yeah yeah what was it that kept you
going
what was it that gave you hope okay
first thing i came across either your
video or grand grand cardone's video
that say
that if you believe you're gonna make it
in life
why not start recording it from day one
so that when you're done with it
you can just look back and see what
you've done so the moment i crossed
about
400 ish rejections and i saw that video
that moment i started recording myself
now bear in mind at that time i used to
live in a house yet
with eight other people so i was sharing
two bathrooms with
seven of the guys my room was basically
about 150 square foot so
single bedroom that was my office my
bedroom was everything
yeah and that's where i started
recording my journey what made me feel
what made me hustle through i think it
comes to the entrepreneurship drive
it wasn't really about the money you
make at the end of it it was rather the
game it's like why can't i figure this
game out
like curiosity i think that was it it's
just the entrepreneurship drive that one
has within himself
yeah well congrats to keep going what
did you think when he landed his first
deal
oh i was i was over them yeah i still
remember
like you know this just took me like a
way back in memory lane and i was so
happy for him
and you know because i saw him go
through that you know there was a time
where he had a choice of coming to see
me because it had been eight months
since we hadn't seen each other but
that's because he was so busy with work
and he had a chance or he invests that
same money into you know
doing something with you and you know
buying books and personal development so
i told him
you know do that you know so i was very
happy that it worked out like i felt
like you know so he's saying that
he couldn't he used all the money that
he had instead of going on a flight to
dubai to see you
instead he used it going on a course to
see me yeah yeah
wow yeah knowledge is key
yeah but but but again i also think that
sometimes people
it's hard for me because when people are
in that kind of situation whereby
they've not got a lot
and they've been burned before maybe
throughout through mistakes or through
rejections or whatever it might be
and then they're like this is the last
bit of money i've got
for me that's a real responsibility yeah
because i'll either be
you know a saint or i'll be satan yeah
because if it doesn't work i'll be one
of those guys that will be like oh where
are you guys it didn't work
but i'm very confident in the training
yeah you know i'm very confident that it
works
yeah and i always tell people it's not a
guarantee you're gonna have to put the
work in
but it's an opportunity it's a process
not a promise
i can't guarantee it's gonna work but i
can guarantee my track record
yeah yeah and and and thank god that you
had the hope and then went and took the
massive action
yeah so that first deal then where did
you say that was in celio student market
tell me about that first deal okay so i
think
after me building report with them they
gave me the first property
that was just the first problem now now
came in the second problem
i knew how to advertise on spare room
but i wasn't getting any leads
i got three weeks grace period at the
time and
every every two three days i would start
recording myself uh at the time not
posting anything but just recording for
my my own self
and seeing where i was uh when i look
back through the videos i'm like
every day i was so worried because the
contract had signed was 1560
for the month yeah and i within the
first 10 days maybe i had
no lead no no no i was scared
i was scared that the fear was so real
yeah i i started getting desperate then
so i started dropping the rents because
i watched you say
everything will rent if the price is
right yeah so i started dropping the
prices down
got a few inquiries brought them to the
property
and they wouldn't be salts i started
training i started purchasing sales
books and trying to learn how to sell
yeah um tried every different strategy i
possibly could
i would say maybe i had about another 10
days before the rent period started
i was like i need to do something else
so what i now did was printed leaflets
with photographs of the property staged
it up really nicely had some painting
done on it
and i went around the neighborhood spent
about five hours walking into every shop
and telling them hey guys we have a
really nice property down the road
i'll give you a good discount the code
is this i just made a quote
made a quote up and said if you come
down i'll give you 10 15 discount
and i did that for every shop around the
area there was kfc dfc
papa john's the carpet shop everything
you are relevant
yeah it was crazy i'd see students on
the road and i'd ask him hey do you know
anyone looking for a room
here's a leaflet if you want one yeah
and they'll be like hey no
they just walk away so that was that was
bad i didn't get anything from that but
it was a learning curve
outside the property i'd try stick the
leaflets there um on the pool
stick it there anyway um long story
short within the
as the gray spirit came to an end um i
already paid the first month's rent
anyway
if i had to pay the second month's rent
i had the property tenanted
oh wow that's so good so how long did it
take to fully tenant the property i
would say probably about
six four to six weeks okay but i wasn't
too worried because as soon as the first
month really started i already had
uh three to four tenants that could at
least cover the rent the rest of it was
margin
so you say grace period what do you mean
by that
um the the term i negotiated with the
landlord in this case the agent saying
that hey listen i'm gonna
refurb the property for you and the
landlord and that behalf could you
please give me
three weeks when free right that that
buys me the time to refurb the property
yes so they would do it so how much
money did you have to invest
in total to secure that rent to rent um
luckily i didn't have to pay deposit so
that was great
first month rent it was 1560. yeah um
with regards to the painting of course
at the time i was starting up so i
didn't have
funds so i found the guy i said hey
we'll buy the paint let's do it together
so the paint probably costed us about 20
pound a bucket
um i would say save aside 200 pound for
a six bedroom house painting
uh staging material maybe another 200
pound i saved three rooms up and that
move things around
yeah so i'd say probably just under
under 500 pounds maybe got it all up and
running so
very very little money yes to get it up
and running yes
how much profit did that start making
you
um i was renting each room out for 400
to 430
yeah so on top of my head say six rooms
that's 2 400
i'd pay the landlord 1560. yeah
so with the remaining say a thousand
pounds i would pay for the electric gas
water wi-fi council tax
yeah and a free weekly cleaner okay so
that would still be making me 600 to
750 a month incredible yeah good first
deal
and at that point how did it feel again
when realizing
i'm making profit now making 670 pound a
month like
when did you realize that yes this is
the real deal this is happening as soon
as it got tenanted i was like i want
more now
okay because what i also did realize is
when you get into something you're not
going to know it all
you will never know it all yes i didn't
know how to reference a tenant
yeah um as soon as i had enquiries and
the person said i want your room i was
like okay what do i do now
yeah you know what's interesting that
you said as well you said when you got
that first property you had another
problem
yes we will always have problems to
begin with the problem is i can't find a
deal then the problem is i can't fill
the rooms then the problem is
i've got tenants don't want to move in
but i don't know how to reference them
yes then the problem is i need a next
deal like there's always problems then
the problem is i've got too many deals i
need some staff
then the problem is this stuff isn't
performing like you're always going to
have problems yeah and sometimes people
worry about the as i say the xyz problem
yeah when they should be worrying about
the abc you know
and that's what we do at the deal
finding extravaganza we do it's very abc
so let's get a deal right now yeah how
did you find that first deal tell me
what exactly what happened
uh the first deal yeah the one from the
dfa uh
well i just started picking up the phone
because i think with with your courses
one thing that is different is that you
actually make the time because you know
the people once they go back home
they're probably not going to make the
time
to make the call so you encourage them
saying hey we're going to take 20
minutes break
make the calls now yeah so that was
really great that gave me some
enthusiasm some motivation
because truth be told looking back now
at that first point i was scared to pick
up the phone and just
call an agent for property i was like
what am i gonna say what if they call me
a bluff
you know but now looking back i'm like
wow that has been a great progression
yes i would say yeah the dfe really
helped yeah and and um another thing as
well is
when you're in the right mood and the
right environment and you've got people
around that are also doing the calls
it's much easier to do it in that
environment than when you get home
and you forgot the scripts and the
energy is different so why are you in
the right energy
it's like do it now and and i'm really
glad that that got you a deal yeah and
then you ended up getting another deal
another day on another deal and now
you've got 250 units
yeah yeah which is ridiculous and you
came on the discovery day around my
house
yes we've we've done things i mean at
what point
did you realize when did you realize
that
this is this is going good now to be
honest i realized it in the second deal
because i told him
that there is nothing you can't not do
yeah and
when he explained to me the way you were
you are and stuff and i felt like
you you have the right mentorship you
have you're on the right path
there's no way that you're you're
through like for me in my eyes
he was through in the second deal yeah
i'm not just saying it because he's my
husband
but i at that time told him i was not
worried i was like oh you know you
you'll make it right and i tell them
this every day you know you'll make it
right like you'll make it big
you need that support in your life so
yeah i would say that but i just felt
that he he made it through
after the second deal although i just
sound very i might sound very cheesy or
very like you know
but i i just felt that and i would tell
my parents as well i'd be like oh boss
is doing so great
he's you know you know so yeah for me in
my eyes
that's so good and i think as you know i
always say your first deal is the
hardest
and the second hardest is the second
yeah and then the third and the fourth
and the fifth it gets easier and easier
so of your 250 units what does that
consist of
we have a commercial block four blocks
combined together
uh 30 serviced offices there
we have hmos ranging from
four beds now actually we got rid of all
the four beds because that burned me
quite a bit
we got rid of all the four beds uh five
bed up to 32 bedroom
hmo we actually have one really nice one
15 bed all on suite
we have apartment blocks like seven bed
seven apartments all in one
unit we have newly constructed satina
park so it really ranges from apartments
to houses because we also manage a few
properties
why did you what why do four beds not
work to a lot of interest uh
well because that one in specifics celio
in fact it was my third deal it's the
same agent
they were really happy with what i did
so i went back to them and said hey look
that's tenanted
i want some more so they actually
trusted me with two more on top of that
so that was amazing
but the third one that they gave me it
was four bed
one bath um next to the university they
wanted 800 pounds
right we were managing to fill up three
rooms out of the out of the four
and the tenants were paying about 350.
yeah so if we
were one room down having all the bills
electric gas water wi-fi complex and the
cleaner we were not profiting
yeah right sure yeah so it was it was
not worth it
yeah so it's about getting that sweet
spot deal yes i needed to talk to you
actually i'll get my wife to talk to you
about some of the some properties we've
got in sadio
which we might be able to do some
business on yes but um we talk about
that after
after the interview so okay um
what's going on now then like what's the
crack what are you doing tell me about
the staff that you've got on stuff
okay so we i came through the discovery
day yeah i was like okay samuel we're
netting this amount
how do i 10x that now because we have
all these units but i'm not being able
because i'm because i do believe in
mentorship
right with all these things and what
i've realized is the only way i managed
to grow my income
is when i view my personal development
my
knowledge the skills so you've taught me
a lot yeah and i realized you have
many mentors you have grant cardone you
have you had uh was it um
sir what's his name uh yeah
you have loads right so i decided i'll
do the same
i'll have you as my mentor grant grant
cardone i paid for his mentorship
program
prayed for brandon dawson's uh program
paid for jackie edwards and i have a few
successful people within my community
who i call for advice for example the
first employee i wanted to hire
i was so worried i was like what if what
if they steal everything i do and then
go and start their own business right i
didn't know that i could set up a
contract with them and have the
non-confidentiality agreement nda
agreement yeah all these kind of stuff
so i get i get my ideas from everyone
and you advise me that rent to rent is a
perfect model to start off with
right when in terms of getting banking
my first million
that may be slightly difficult or may
take longer
compared to if i went through
developments correct so i was like all
right that's something so i left this
place and i was like okay i need to get
into development
but then again um it's starting fresh
now
slightly fresh and now it's a different
ball game entirely yeah so i didn't also
want to let go of the rental rentals
doing i wanted to find out
how else can i increase my revenue yeah
from the same model
then after about eight months of
research trying to get a contract with a
local authority
we managed to get a contract for
supported accommodation right it's the
same model we rent a property from a
landlord
but rather than housing professionals we
house the homeless
so it's a different ball game entirely
in how we house the tenants
but the model is slightly similar it's
still a brand to rent so these kind of
tenants are homeless
depressed alcoholics drug addicts we
have to house them we need to have
support workers
the support workers need to be competent
enough to help them
eventually live independently yeah so
they need to give them support sessions
every week
right right how are you keeping on why
are you not applying for a job
how are you stopping your drug abuse all
that kind of stuff that goes in place
so that's the business model we have as
well as the developments that we're
trying to
get to as well so the scheme we're
looking at now it's in aston
it's 37 000 square foot upline planning
granted for 40 apartments
amazing parking spaces 50 parking spaces
that's great and that's the thing you
you know cash flow from rent to events
is great but then moving on to really
build wealth
i think it makes sense to step into that
and i love how you've also taken the
strategies
from from the training like rent to
rents and hmos but then you've slowly
adapted it into your own
thing yeah yeah your own niche and
that's the thing i think being an
entrepreneur
um yes you have to follow a template but
also you have to have space for creative
flair and things so how would you
how would you say how's life changed
from say two years ago to now
so from engagement to married life yeah
just everything how's life different now
um so i would say that in terms of my
drive that i had before
i think it's definitely increased a lot
because now i see him
with a lot of work and everything and i
go to the office every day and
you know i'm there and i'm making so
many things happen so i
obviously am more like focused more
business-minded
than i was when i was engaged because
you know when you're far
i can hear your stories but i can't feel
you no because i'm not there to see you
but now when i came here and like you
know was all like okay
this needs to be done that needs to be
done you know let's do this let's do
that so i started going
okay let's try this let's try that so i
i feel like
it's changed a lot it's matured me yeah
i feel
and you know the wealth of knowledge
that i've gained within real estate
about you about like everything in
general within uk
i would have never gotten that if i was
still in dubai of course so i was very
much a baby there
and i feel here i've grown ten years
yeah
well you haven't i mean sometimes
becoming a millionaire it's not about
the million it's about who you become
in the process yeah you know what about
you how's life changed as a result of
the business blown up oh it is so good
i think it's that once you've made so
much happen
you get into that mindset that anything
is possible now yeah
if you put your work to it you're hard
to it it is all possible
what sort of um what sort of profits or
revenue are you generating okay so when
i first came to you
discovery day i think it was about nine
months ago maybe i
remember at that point i was netting
about ten thousand pounds
yeah but at that point i was also
running around like i had this ticket i
wasn't necessarily working on the
business
too much i was working in the business i
love sales myself yeah
trying to get the properties because i
know it's so hard sometimes to get it
but
but the thrill that you get after it's
so pleasurable so i was working into
sales quite a bit
and then getting your advice on how i
can 10x that i changed a lot of the
things
at some point i dropped my net margins
at the time employed more people
yeah and now i would say i'm in a very
good position to be able to
uh bank my first million very soon wow
fantastic
i'm excited i'm excited and your staff
how did you find them and what happened
uh okay first thing i didn't know how to
find them okay
i found a person who's told me of us
i'll charge you um
was it 10 off their annual wage to find
a good employee
i was like all right sure let's do it
and he started sending me about 80 to 90
cvs uh over a week and i was like none
of these are good i didn't know how to
advertise for it
yeah uh and then one family friend we
hired the first one
but for the second one she was already
on board she's like why don't we figure
it out ourselves
so we went to google advertise wrote
down on google how do i hire an employee
that we came across indeed total jobs
linkedin and we're like oh that's it
so we started putting our adverts there
i think was it 15 pounds a day or
something we were paying yeah
and yeah we would get amazing um
enquiries
so that's how we got them what would you
say your strongest reason is
for do i mean you you went through some
serious rejection yeah you know
some serious hard work heartache blood
sweat tears
what's what's the strongest reason for
going all through that why are you doing
this
i'll say three things i guess it comes
down to number one i love it yeah the
passing for properties
number two uh sarah and i we set an
urgency
to our goals we don't want to be
billionaires
at the age of 60. we want to enjoy it
while we're still
in 30s yeah right so whatever goal we
have we
10x the goal so if i want to make say 50
000 pounds per month i will not keep 50
as my goal i'd rather keep it as 500 000
pounds as my goal
then i'll put in more effort it's a 10x
rule i'll put in so much more effort
more marketing more investment more time
more everything
and then even if i fall short of 500 000
pounds from one
i'll still be more ahead than 50 000
pounds yeah so i put an urgency to
everything i have yeah making it look
like
i don't have the time to waste yeah and
i think was it the 80 20
the low pareto's low something like the
parkinson's low that you utilize the
time
entirely to the goal that you have in
space so if we set ourselves five years
ago to accomplish that time we will take
five years
if we compress it to 12 months we can
even do it that's exactly what we do you
know yeah
take people i'll ask people what's your
five or ten year goal and then just
bring it down to
ten weeks yeah like crazy and that's
what what you've done
um i mean you must have seen something
in a bath as well you say you always
believed in him and
i mean a couple years ago you were
basically a bit of a loser really
you know you were banging on doors
getting rejected earning no money
scrapping around you know you're failing
miserably at that time yeah but then you
knew that he was going to be successful
one day you saw something in him what
was it that you saw
it actually um he's what happened was
this is a bit personal but i would love
to share this with you and you know
everybody watching um my grandfather
he was he was he started off with from
scratch he didn't have anything
and he became he worked really hard and
he did really well in his life
like really really well and he always
told and the way he was he was very
he because he was such a hard worker and
because i saw those qualities in him
i felt okay you know this is something
you know i i
because i don't want an and he doesn't
want to settle for less
from day one he would always tell me you
know let's let's do something let's do
something big
it's just that we didn't know what it
would be or what he wanted to do
so when i used to see these qualities in
him i used to feel like i'm it's a lot
like my grandfather it's a lot like my
family
so because i was born in a place where i
was very much protected
i felt he had those qualities and
i was like okay you know what i think
they even share the same birth date
so i just was like okay you know what
this is right like you're that you're
the one for me you know i know you're
gonna go far you're gonna make it
and obviously you know it's not just
that it's also about the way he talks to
me the conversations he would have
and you know instead of talking about
like you know just anything he would
always like to bring in business or like
let's talk about like
how to multiply this or like let's talk
about this venture or that venture
or you know i'm trying to start this out
so you know it kind of gave me a lot
about him
and how he is as a person that he likes
to talk about knowledge he likes to talk
about business
he likes to talk about money he loves
money
conversations change on the dining table
yeah like
i would start off with just talking
about today and by the end we're just
talking about how
we should develop this or do that or
tomorrow we should call the solicitors
and talk about this
so he's definitely become a great
businessman there's no doubt
so going like yeah so going back to when
i was like you know he is the person
it's because of
all the characteristics that he has now
yeah he's amplified it but at that time
he had those as well
and he would talk to me about his dreams
and passions and it would always lead to
being something big he wanted to make it
big yeah
so i felt like okay you know this
reminds me of my family
and is he a good husband as well sorry
yeah good husband
he's really sweet yeah yeah and a good
wife
oh amazing you guys are such a great
couple i think one of the things i see
in you as well
is your a couple things number one is
your serious
uh resilience yeah and then secondly is
your
how addicted you are to growth yeah
because
if you grow as a person your your bank
will grow
and you've been growing like crazy and
through the discomfort and through the
rejection
it's been actually growing you outside
your comfort zone through the
i know i went on some training
previously i it didn't really work out
but i'm gonna do it again yeah
yeah and i'm gonna and i'm gonna step
out and i'm gonna grow and as you've
done that you've grown and then your
bank has grown
and then with a wife who believes in you
yeah it's just such a beautiful story
yeah i think that compatibility is so
important for everyone to be on the same
page
but then a lot of people would have seen
you two years ago
and wouldn't have seen what you saw they
would have just seen a loser or
a wannabe a talker but now you've backed
it up
yeah did you have people at the time a
couple years ago that maybe said be
careful or
you know weren't sure about you well yes
of course uh
well see i i think before before god you
want to decide something don't worry
yeah there were quite a few people yeah
because you were like a little bit kind
of and she was like
tell me what what happened no i mean i
just feel like there are so many people
that say oh i don't think you should do
this and i feel like they were always
putting a stop
and they were always putting fear but
i'll tell you why i can also empathize
with them to some extent
while growing up i gave you my story
with my father beforehand he grew up
he was selling oranges on his wedding
day nothing but he died a multi
multi-millionaire with so much land
import export all that
and then we kind of lost it all because
there was nobody to look after it
so when a family has been burned so much
they're not in a position to take risks
right so it's some it's subconsciously
and
unintentionally as well that they're
telling you not to do something because
they're scared
for you to get burned right so there's a
family side and then
those people who maybe just
intentionally don't want you to succeed
yeah right
they'd say hey don't do that don't go
too big you know there's so much
problems you're gonna face after
so it is important to to have the right
people around you that is so important
i think most even friends most of your
friends they want you to do well but as
long as you're not doing better than
them
yeah but if you're friends with people
that are just working a normal job and
they don't want you to do better than
them it's just going to keep you in that
bubble yeah like
like a a bucket of crabs that can't keep
pulling each other down
whereas i think certainly the
environment that we've created is a
group of people that are trying to give
each other a leg up
yeah you know through the training and
and the network um
what would you say has been the
highlight of the of the entire process
of the last couple of years
i think the realization that knowledge
is everything
um over the past two and a half years
before i even started a business i don't
think i missed a week where i haven't
completed a book
wow so it's one book a week i've
probably invested
more than 20 000 pounds on personal
development courses
not just property courses sales courses
marketing courses all these other types
of courses yeah
so the fact that i've realized that
invest your money and knowledge that
information okay it's just a simple
scenario if i'm going to tell you about
spend 50 000 pounds
so two years later you can have 500 000
pounds yeah it's a no-brainer well in
your case if you're about to bag a
million
yeah and you spent 20 grand yeah that's
two percent
yeah that's two percent you have to i
think you have to invest in yourself
you know before you invest in anything
else property or business
because again the bigger you grow the
bigger your bank will grow
and even if you if two years ago if
your dad or whoever or me had given you
a million pounds
it wouldn't have done anything for you
very cheap it's about who you become in
making the money
yeah you know so absolutely fabulous um
final words of wisdom and advice you can
go first someone watching this that's
thinking
um like a bass was two years ago i'm
banging on the doors and getting
rejected
i've been burned my family are worried
and skeptical i've got nothing
but i have a burning desire in my heart
to grow big what would you say
if you can think it and you can dream it
then you can do it
there's no way if but if you can but but
if you feel you can't do it you'll never
do it
you can never do it yeah so it's all in
your head if you can actually
dream it and i tell about this every day
if if you thought about it if you know
you you can if you can dream it then
there's definitely you can
you need to see it and then you need to
make it live yeah but if you say
to yourself you can't do it you'll never
do it you can never do it
awesome i think while he was talking it
just
clicked my mind that there was a point
in life
where i had banked about 50 000 pounds
and i was thinking that i was gonna
spend this money into buying
my very first property at the time but
looking back i'm so glad i didn't do
that
rather i used that money to invest in
myself and in business
yeah and that business has just grown so
much they can take me to places and have
more properties now
um so that's just one thing i wanted to
share but for for somebody
out there like me number one just invest
in yourself
um they would say that okay i'd rather
take a risk into property and all that
kind of stuff buying a property or
invest in something but this is just two
thousand pounds even even if it doesn't
work out
it's a risk you might go to eight
courses they all might fail but the
ninth one might just hit
and that might just take you to places
yeah so i think it's just invest in
yourself crash courses they shouldn't
miss out
especially you do it for free crash
courses yeah so
that's a no-brainer yeah yeah yeah the
crash course actually we're back now so
we're doing tours and stuff across
across the country
then the property investors crash course
it's free and then we have the advanced
training deal finding extravaganza
um but what's it been what's the
experience be like what's it been like
working with me now for the last
couple years oh it's been amazing i
think you've been really genuine
um i i appreciate you on the dfe well no
before the dfv on the first crash course
telling you hey samuel i've seen this
three bed property
i'm looking i'm doing a rent 280 more on
this uh
would you share some like what do you
think you're actually you were quite
busy and i didn't expect you to take out
the time into actually studying the deal
but you came outside like let me have a
look you looked at the floor plan you
looked at the price and you're like
you'll get burnt down on this one and it
was a three bed and it's true now that i
look back if i did go on it three bed
and the location as a hmo
i would have been burnt yeah so i felt
your advice was actually genuine and you
do care for the people that you work
with
yeah so for me it's been amazing i
really appreciate that guys
massive congratulations um can't wait to
stay in touch if someone wants to get in
touch with you what's the best way
okay so first thing um i have a website
10xrising.com so that's 10xrising.com
yeah
you can text me on 007-481-297-895
and well yes i have a book publishing
very soon in two days
so make sure you buy that it's called
property investments
simplified so i hope that helps hey dude
massive congrats
and also the fact that you've become
successful now you're not hiding away
you're sharing you're talking you're
connecting
um much much much love and respect so
get in touch with these guys i think
you'll agree what a fabulous story
and listen if they've been able to do
that over the last couple of years
starting with nothing
now i've got 200 properties that they
control
nine full-time members of staff just
with resilience
and knowledge you can do that too you
don't have to be born with a silver
spoon in your mouth
you just need to keep working hard and
keep growing and getting the knowledge
if you want to join me at the property
investors crash course or any of our
training
i'd like to give you free tickets i'll
leave a link in the description
get down come and meet me maybe i'll be
able to review your deal as well
like i did a bass so get booked on i'll
see you real soon
i've done over a hundred of these
interviews this
stuff works check out the interviews
come to the crash course
kick some ass i'll see you soon
you